you've seen some some uh hacker moves in
the 90s quite often
included a certain scene where you'd
have a lovely
super villain style map of the world and
somebody would say something like
oh my goodness the police are
intercepting the call and you see a
lovely map and you see a little line
working its way across the map what i
would try and do is use
some uh standard unix tools traceroute
which
uh a lot of people who've done system
administration be very very familiar
with
i thought i'd hack up a bit of python
and see what we can see
see if we can get something that looks a
little bit like that classic hacker
movie scene
we're going to auckland university in
new zealand
and now we can get up our result and we
can see it's hopping
from the uk oh to america
over to the west coast america and then
a massive transoceanic cable
all the way into the ocean winding up in
new zealand
i'd like to talk about the traceroute
command and uh is it
as it sounds traces a route yeah
but actually there's quite a quite
beautiful little
hack here it's quite a nice um nice way
that it's working
so i'd like to explain that show a few
examples and
sure you can be a little bit of a
tourist using traceroute you can learn a
bit
about how the network is working
this is the network the internet right
the internet of course yes it works for
the whole internet
with some caveats which i'll explain so
in theory we can find the route from
anywhere that we've got access to a
computer to anywhere else
in theory let me draw a few
routers or routers if you're an american
and let's imagine i'm
sitting here this is my laptop
some server up here and
there's some kind of network
connecting all of these things and we
want to be able to answer the question
which way is the traffic really going
before we learn about traceroute there's
another command we need to think about
and that's ping pings
a lovely little utility that you use
just to test
if something's alive if a bit of network
hardware
is connected to the network written in
it sends out an internet control message
and the message is icmp
echo request it asks a computer
or a router to send back a message
saying
i'm live i'm working okay
so if we want to check if a particular
computer is working
we send out that ping icmp echo request
and if it is working that computer sends
back icmp
echo reply and the ping command
gets that back and you know that you've
got a connection to our computer
now what we want to know now not just
that
this machine here is working
and responding to pings but we also want
to know the route
now this wasn't actually designed into
the internet this ability
it was hacked in later something we need
to know about here is what's called
time to live every internet protocol
packet when it's created
is set up with this flag time to live
it's as if they've all got a doomsday
clock on them
um we've got a little counter
every time the packet goes through a
router
that time to live counter decrements by
one so
and there's a very good reason for that
because if your network is misconfigured
you can get what we call a routing loop
so
imagine somehow we'd messed up our
configuration
and traffic that was meant to go to this
red router here
ends up going around in a circle and
that can happen
now once that starts to happen the
traffic's just going to carry on
going around in that loop you've got big
problem because
that's going to fill up your network so
they made this little design choice to
have the time to live counter
and when that reaches zero they just go
this packet's stuck
it's expired we're going to throw it
away and this
allows a really neat trick so this was
created by van jacobson one of the great
creators of the internet he's
one of the men who made the internet
work and helped in the fundamental
design of transmission control protocol
but also this is of just a brilliant
contribution
because he realized that this time to
live counter
could be exploited normally you'd set it
very high so that the only reason it
would expire is if your packet was stuck
in one of these routing loops
but if you cheat a bit if you set that
route
that time to live very very low
you can set it to one so my packet sets
off from here
gets here the time to live was one and
the packet is expired
the router then must send back a ttl
expired message which you can get back
to your computer
and now you've got a message from this
first hop go again
set the time to lift to two it
decrements to one
decrements again and now you're going to
get ttl expired
from this route here you're going to
find out what your second hop is
time to lift three get a message from
this one time to live
four you get a message from this one and
by sending
subsequent packets with different time
to lives
you can find out every hob on your
journey
very neat that's cool it's very cool
there's a little catch
because actually you're not really
getting a root
these are different packets so if you
play with this command enough sometimes
you'll see
that in between this packet being sent
and this packet being sent maybe the
roots have changed
sometimes changed so sometimes you get
something where the second hop is here
but then the third hop is also here
because the route originally was like
that
and the route was switched to be like
that and the route was changed halfway
through your probe
but it's it's a lovely little hack
that can tell you the way packets find
the way through a network
what i thought i'd try and do is get a
little bit of python together to sort of
try and
capture that that thing of uh the
packets leaping across the map of the
world
so let's first let's just have a look at
a basic ping command
which i'm sure most of you see before so
i'm going to use universe
there's a very good reason i'm using
universities we don't always have
a huge budget so we we tend to have our
web server being
one machine somewhere in iraq um
other companies big companies like
google they're doing something a little
more sophisticated so if i ping my
university queen mary university
we're gonna get ping back
but we can also trace through to it
so this is a traceroute going from my
flat
in south london well from my isp down to
queen mary
university and we can see in the middle
here
it's going through janna the giant
academic network
a little thing that's happened here it's
going to the stars
that means some network administrator in
the intervening path
is blocking our packets now there's a
number of reasons that administrators
decide i don't want these ping packets i
don't want these tracery packets on my
network
there used to be an attack called a
smurf attack where people used ping
to to cause all kinds of network
disruption but also you might decide
you know what you don't want external
people
to know what your interior network
wiring looks like
so we when we get to these stars that
means the administrator there has taken
the decision
to block my internet control message
protocol
my uh requests to see inside their
network
we'll try a nice long tray suit and we
think sydney university is a good long
way away so we might see something
interesting
each of these lines is one hop of the
journey
but there's actually each hop of the
journey we've got three packets so we
get three estimates
of the round trip time so here we can
see it's jumped from 52 milliseconds
response
to 250 milliseconds response so we can
infer
that between hot 11 and hop 15 here it's
probably gone across an ocean
and maybe here between hop where it's
250 at hops 17
and here probably it's gone across
another ocean there so we're getting
eventually
360. well i discovered something quite
nice here
if i actually go for the web server so i
go to the www.sydney.edu.edu
we'll see a little bit of a different
story it stops a lot earlier
it stops here at this akamai
technologies i don't know if you know
the company akamai
is that like a local copy or something
yes exactly that yeah brilliant yeah
that's exactly what it is
a lot of people don't know about them
but these companies like akamai and
limelight content
cdn content distribution content
delivery networks
most of the traffic you get off the
internet if you're going to youtube
netflix whatever
you aren't going to a single server
somewhere in america
you're going to the local copy they've
mirrored
and sydney university has quite sensibly
decided you know what we're in australia
we're a long way from a lot of people
are trying to access our website
we'll pay these people a bit of money
and they'll they'll put a copy
closer so that's quite an interesting
thing we can see
but the other thing i thought i'd do is
to um
turn this into that scene we sometimes
see in the hacker movies or a little bit
so let's look over here at some point we
can do what we call ipg geolocation
doesn't always work what we try and do
is take an ip address
and work out where it is in the world so
here's a little bit of python code
that takes a string that's an internet
protocol address
i'm using version 4 because i'm
old-fashioned and i'm kind of used to
that
but this is taking that string sending
out to this particular
company getting back a response
and we can pass out of that response
that company gives us
a latitude and a longitude now there's
no
mechanism in the internet that allows
that
all they've done is they've got a
database and they're saying
who owns that ip address
so it's not always perfectly accurate
you get some funny things coming up
like if the only thing they know is that
that company
is in america it will return the
latitude and longitude
the center yeah the very geographical
dead center of america
that has some really peculiar effects
uh people who think they know a little
bit more than they actually know
they go who's the ip address that's
annoyed me
i'll find the latitude longitude and
show up there
people who live in that middle address
in america that's in the very middle of
america sometimes find
random strangers showing up at their
house annoyed with them because they
think some company lives there or
they think somebody's trying to hack
them from there sorry to those people
living in that home
yeah it's actually is really unfortunate
for them because until ipg location was
a thing it was just some address in
america
but now it's the very middle of america
can work out very unhappily for them so
this is the bit of code anyway that
takes this string i p address
sends out a request gets some jason back
passes that jason and gets me a latin
long and i've got some base error
checking this is not brilliant code i
hacked it together in an hour
a couple of nights ago now the other
thing i need to do
is send out a traceroute command so
here's a python sending out a traceroute
to some
ip address that i'm going to pass in
from the command line i'm going to use
some basic map plotting and i'm going to
pass through
the individual lines of my command line
output
split out the ip address on this line
here
do some basic passing to see if it's one
of those stars or an
error line and if
i have a new latitude and longitude
and if i've got some previous latitude
and longitude
i'm going to draw a great circle line so
i'm just calling a library routine here
to do it
and plot that on the map so let's have a
look at that working to somewhere
interesting so if we go to the
sydney dot edu dot ayu
you'll take a little bit of time to go
through the traceroute command
and we'll see it's working there sending
out those sequences of three packets
and now it's going to pop up the map of
the world and we can see more or less
where it's going so there's one big
great circle hop from london i suspect
i'm not sure i suspect that that is that
is that middle of america address
i told you about that's definitely not
new york is it
no no no that's not new i suspect that
all it knows about the server there
is it's in america and that's the middle
we've got a hop out to the west coast
there looks like it's somewhere in
california and then bang all the way
down to
australia i think we can also say look
kink there as it comes in
on the coast there and then makes its
way down to sydney for the final bit
can we try somewhere random somewhere
different uct
cape town today okay cape town very nice
place yeah
so now we're doing our route to cape
town south africa
i have no idea what this one will
actually look like
okay it's going by the way i'm always
doing the web server
because i i suspect that the web server
will be a single machine on that
oh well that's not as interesting as i
uh we can't see too much i don't think
that's a full great circle i think
there's a there's a sort of central hop
there
if we hop over to tokyo so let's try and
get us over to the
university of tokyo which is in japan
and again
it's going to pop up the route we can
see when we get a big jump from 27 to
that's it jumping over an ocean that's
jumping over another one so it's
interesting to me that it tends to go
westly
is that because of america being a
powerhouse in the internet
you can also find that sometimes
different places even with their country
will swap around and
i have seen this i'm not going to run it
until it does but i have seen this swap
round
and and at another time of day it will
take the eastbound route
blue cost of one and
nothing else because we haven't yet
switched on green
so now our black is switched on blue
direction the signal is moving in so the
speed of those pulses tell us the rate
we know which direction it is because we
know which roller is coming from and we
can look